team that went four and 12 last year
with not
very bad injury luck pretty good injury
luck um
you don't have many guys under contract
though the salary caps pretty tight what
are the avenues available to you to
improve this roster
i think everything's in consideration um
and and look that there's
we're gonna have to make some hard
decisions on some players on this roster
and and we're gonna have to earn our job
the scouts right we're scouts so we're
gonna have to go find players because
you you can't just build your roster
with overpaid players and free agency or
top draft bits um we gotta really dig we
have to dig and and find value in free
agency and and that's working with the
coaches and that's um finding out
exactly what they need and going and
finding the players that they need
that's in that's throughout the entire
draft and that's an undrafted free
agency um so we have to be scouts and we
have to go find good players that um
that really fit the make up and the
profile that we're looking for
yeah i wouldn't have wanted that job if
i was terry fontenot or arthur smith
because this year is going to be a
difficult year now if ownership
understands that if rich mckay the team
ceo understands it it's kind of like a
scholarship year because you're dealing
with a huge cap situation
matt ryan has a 40.9 million dollar cap
number and if they traded him it would
have been close to that they still could
trade him but i think they decided we're
taking a huge cap number charge on this
guy anyway we may as well have him on
the team but the real challenge moving
forward shireen how do they put a team
around matt ryan julio jones both both
reportedly coming back both have huge
cap numbers both would have huge cap
consequences if traded they're gonna
have to make the most of this effort to
go out and sign guys who are cut by
other teams who don't get what they're
looking for in free agency and they're
gonna have to recruit the hell out of
those guys to come to atlanta and get
them to believe that the falcons with
the right supporting cast could be a
special team again like they were a few
years back
yeah and i don't know that that's going
to happen mike and good luck to terry
fontenot and good luck to arthur smith
and in trying to get this done i just
don't see it happening this year and
they're going to shed some of these
contracts to get back to to where they
once were with which was really close to
winning a super bowl and they haven't
been the same team
since then and you look at you know when
they last won when they last won the
division and and it's been a while and
so they have a lot to to address this
offseason they have a lot to address
into the future mike and and this is
another job we talked about the steelers
i wouldn't want the steelers job right
now to to try to address the cap
situation and ben roethlisberger's
future and not having a quarterback of
the future it's the same with the
falcons i mean they're up against it on
the cap and i just don't know what you
do here good luck terry font no and and
good luck to the falcons i will say this
they won four games last year i do think
they were better than that i know your
record is
what you are is what your record says
you is but you know you look at all the
blown leads they had and everything that
happened to them i do think they're
better than that how much better
probably like these seven and nine they
were in the two years before that
somewhere in that range so a little bit
better than what they were in four games
but i don't see this team as a
contending team as you were rattling off
that parcel saying i almost thought i
was working with sims again this
afternoon you sure you got that right
yeah i butched it no i butchered it
it was horrible
that's okay join the club you haven't
you haven't done live tv of a of a five
letter network or streaming variety
until you've butchered something um
i just they're gonna have to butcher
this roster they're gonna have to have
major major changes and i don't know
what they're going to have going forward
and if i'm matt ryan i don't even want
to be there i remember arthur blank at
one point saying whether or not matt
ryan's on the team in 2021 is partially
going to be a factor of whether he wants
to be i don't know
why well i know i don't know maybe he
didn't see another opportunity for him
out there maybe his agent worked the
angles behind the scenes and realized no
one was jumping up and down for a guy
who's going to be 36 in may
i know there was speculation of of a
reunion with kyle shanahan with the
49ers but
um i i it it's just a shame what the
falcons have been through since that
28-3 debacle and i almost feel like
that's going to hover over that team
until everyone who was connected to that
that game is gone and that includes matt
ryan and julio jones so who knows the
direction it's moving in some believe
this is the last year for jones and ryan
and we'll see maybe they're just on the
team one more year to fill up the
stadium that's something they've
struggled to do i know there were
reports
2019 before the world turned upside down
about teams
about fans excuse me just letting their
psl payments lapse and just giving them
up and when you see a falcons game
there's a lot of empty seats there that
they need to do something to get fans in
the stands and one way to do that is by
winning let's do
our one in and one out shireen you're up
first who's in for the falcons
i'm gonna go with justin fields played
at georgia started his career at georgia
before he went to ohio state and you
talk about selling tickets i don't think
he's their quarterback this year
obviously but but falcons fans will have
something to look forward to to the
future he can sit behind matt ryan this
year and then they give him the job
next year mike but i think justin fields
is going to be the guy for the falcons
in the future
you know his legend has it in nfl
circles matt ryan was an ownership pick
back in 2008 and and
owners are involved a lot more than than
owners will admit they're involved but
maybe this time around owner arthur
blank or ceo rich mckay will say let's
go ahead and nab that quarterback that
can develop let's do it in
unconventional style the new convention
is thrust that rookie in right out of
the gates justin fields if he is the guy
would sit on the bench for a year
potentially and then take over
what i would do if i'm the falcons
i would get myself a young workhorse
tailback in the draft in whatever round
you think you can get him i'm going to
defer to the expertise of terry fontenot
he was part of the saints when they
found alvin kamara go find yourself an
alvin kamara like it's that easy in the
mid rounds of the draft and make that
your guy because that's what they
desperately need to compliment matt ryan
and julio jones and you can find the
right guy who comes in and makes an
impact right away look at what james
robinson undrafted did for the jaguars
last year so i'm not giving a name at
this point what i'm saying is target the
draft one of the rounds of the draft
three four or five get yourself a
running back that you have full faith
can come in and take over the job from
day one and be on the field three downs
at a time and really help the offense
provide a compliment to the passing game
shereen
yeah and this is a team mike that
finished 27th in rushing last year they
need an upgrade at that position and you
talk about arthur smith we know what he
likes to do he likes to run the ball
it's a run first offense and you look at
matt ryan he's had over 600 attempts
over the last three years and a lot of
that is the product of of having to come
from behind being behind in the fourth
quarter and having to throw a lot so i
get that but they do need a better
running game to go with matt ryan so
maybe it's even an instance when you
trade down and you get the other alabama
guy who's supposedly as good or better
than derrick henry has the prospect to
be and nadia harris maybe that's what
you end up doing and get some additional
picks but i am so with you and i was
looking for a running back possibly they
could sign in free agency and they just
don't have the money to sign and aaron
jones or somebody like that so the draft
is probably the best prospect for that
mike gotta go with the draft and if you
do it right you end up with a star
player for four years and then you worry
about paying him a new contract after
that all right who's out for the falcons
who isn't out maybe easier maybe it's
just who isn't out
they've already made a ton of their
moves but i think we can expect todd
gurley to go somewhere else i guess my
question on todd gurley you did sign the
one year 5.5 million dollar deal with
the falcons and and did not live up to
the expectations they had for him his
knees are shot mike and it's a shame
because he had such a great stretch
there with the rams he was so good they
only had one 100 yard game this season
his average
per rush has fallen from three eight to
three five over the last two years fifty
fifty seven point one yards per game in
2019 45.2 yards per game this year my
only question with todd gurley is does
anybody else sign him mike
yeah i i agree with you it may be it for
todd gurley who made a ton of money
coming off of that torn acl that he
suffered at georgia in 2014 was still a
top 10 pick got a contract that the rams
never should have given to him given the
health situation they ended up
regretting it cutting him he made a lot
of money off of that deal though he
should be happy with what he got at the
nfl level and i think that for him the
question now becomes how little are you
willing to take to play because at some
point you just say it's not worth my
time it's not worth my effort it's not
worth the risk of further injury to my
knees or potential cognitive issues in
continuing to play football for
something close to the minimum alex mack
is is going to be gone long time center
on the team and and that's going to be
important uh
to fill that position properly but
they're not going to be able to sign him
they may not want to even try to do it
but just another hole that they're going
to have to fill and a fairly important
one because if you don't have a good
center he gets thrown into the legs of
the quarterback uh and hard to run the
passing game if you have your your
center being thrown at your kneecaps and
and your ankles uh right after you get
the football in your hands
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports